did you expect that movie to be what it
was yeah Charlie's Angels was our intent
was to make Charlie's Angels be you know
like you know we wanted to be female
action absolutely you know and we wanted
it was very for us to like we didn't use
guns we didn't kill anybody we were all
like it was hand-to-hand combat it was
our you know our skill set it's the best
family yeah you you checked all the
boxes
to get families in the theater the
biggest I'll say this okay it's
everybody watching this right now
the biggest goal for any studio uh
uh I won't say for any actor actress but
I'll say for a studio the the biggest
prize if you can somehow do a project
and it's a family project where any and
everybody can come and they can see it
together they can see it as husband and
wife boyfriend and girlfriend they can
see it as mom dad with all the kids Aunt
uncle where you check the boxes where
anybody can come to a theater
that is a Monumental project and not
many can do it you did it and you guys
we did we had so much fun doing it too
it was so perfectly cast yeah it was so
great and Drew you know Drew produced
that she created the opportunity you
know and she was she got me on board and
it was one of the best times you know
making a film ever that I've had you go
out
you're now done all right let's just
fast forward let's get back to almost
where we are now you decide to walk away
I know that you're in love with
motherhood I know she said I kinda miss
it you said I kind of miss it sometimes
I don't actually ever I was going to say
in in a way think about whether or not I
would do it again just to remind me that
I don't want to I was going to say you
know what just hit me what's that you
got out the business before the social
media wave I did
holy cow wait a second let's let's all
take a second and truly acknowledge what
I just said I know isn't it beautiful
Cameron you got out got out
before
the wave of yes that has come with
social media by the way good and bad
right there's good and bad yeah but you
it just hit me yeah it was just in time
it was just like yeah it was like the we
were just tweeting yeah what is that
yeah yeah you get 150 characters I'll
try it yes today I ate pancakes it was
the beginning
and then you just go butter but yeah
today
woke up on time who else who else yes
yes
they're like what are you talking about
what are you talking waking up at the
table in the beginning it wasn't
anything bad it was just it was all
happy me too good morning
I did but this is my problem this is
like I was so reluctant to like dip back
in your mind is really good by the way
thank you good it's delicious it's
really good seriously thank you
um I and you know now with with my wine
I you know try to engage as much as
possible but I just really have zero
I
have zero interest in sharing my life
with people I don't think you should
it's like I don't think you should and
it's so it's so cool because like I get
it like our marketing gals who are
social media gals they're they're
amazing and they understand it like they
get how to make this work and they'll be
like how about if we I'm like nope
I think there is
such an amazing thing
in privacy for those that have chose to
to truly uh prioritize it right like I'm
I'm on the opposite yeah side of the
spectrum I'm as transparent as they come
and I love it you know I take the good
and the bad yeah that's why I'm always
okay if I step in and it's still on
my shoe and I walk I'm fine I open up
for a reason because my life is about
being open whether it's through what you
see on social media at the stage I'm an
open book I tell stories about me and
who I am and what I go very brave it's
very it's what it's going to make me or
break me
[Music]
thank you